Cómo se están produciendo estas
deportaciones en qué condiciones se
producen
Bueno pues estas deportaciones están
dando en el marco del título 42
recordemos que este título 42 lo que
hace es deportar de manera expedita a
las personas en el caso de México pues
ya anteriormente hemos tenido a
diferentes migrantes de otras
nacionalidades vía título 42 entonces
básicamente es una disposición que la
ponen en marcha en la pandemia el
presidente entonces Donald Trump en 2020
y que la ha mantenido el gobierno
estadounidense Aunque ya no tenga ningún
sentido tenerla es decir en su momento
en una exposición de salud pública más
que migratoria pero creo que se ha hecho
un uso abusivo de esta figura más de 2.3
millones de personas han sido deportadas
bajo esta figura el título 42 que lo que
lo que hace es que el centro el cdc de
salud el centro de salud de Estados
Unidos los los decidan Quiénes son
personas que pueden poner en riesgo a
los estadounidenses y en razón de ello
lo pueden los pueden deportar de alguna
manera rápida sin que sigan un debido
proceso en su deportación entonces por
eso se le facilita utilizarlo como una
medida migratoria a pesar de haber sido
creada como una medida de salud pública
Entonces ahora lo que está haciendo el
gobierno estadounidense esa ampliar la
medida que ya no solamente sean
Centroamericanos los que puedan deportar
a México sino también ahora venezolanos
puedan ser parte de estas nacionalidades
que están regresando a México a
diferentes puntos fronterizos como ya
decías Tijuana y Ciudad Juárez han sido
los puntos de mayor afluencia También en
estos programas que dicho sea de paso
son ciudades que tienen alto delictivo y
peligrosidad para los migrantes Y eso lo
hemos visto han abusado de ellos los han
extorsionado en fin realmente así una
situación muy compleja y parece no haber
un plan mayor para estas personas
estamos viendo precisamente un flujo
inédito de personas que están
arriesgando sus vidas cruzando el tapón
del Darién entre Colombia y Panamá para
intentar llegar a Estados Unidos la
mayoría de ellas son de Venezuela esos
24.000 permisos que promete a Estados
Unidos para esos ciudadanos venezolanos
ayudan a mitigar esta crisis migratoria
bueno sin duda es positivo que den esas
24.000 visas humanitarias como las que
dieron en su momento para ucranianos
Aunque fueron 100.000 para procranianos
pero aquí el punto es que estamos viendo
nosotros recibimos desde agenda migrante
ayer de cerca de 200 venezolanos que
están aquí en la Ciudad de México y te
puedo decir que la realidad es que nadie
puede aplicar para esas visas
humanitarias porque te piden uno de los
requisitos es que tengas pasaporte que
haya centrado legalmente a México en fin
diversas cosas que nadie de estas
personas que ya venían huyendo y que
vienen en el camino y que requieren
también el apoyo pues cumple con esos
requisitos muchos de los que vienen
viajando por el daríen y por la por
tierra es debido que México también
metió a petición creo yo de Estados
Unidos un requisito de visa hacia los
venezolanos y para la visa tienes que
tener 700 dólares de ganancia al mes más
de 2500 dólares en tu cuenta en menos
demostrado tres meses en fin realmente
es imposible para alguien de Venezuela
con la situación como está ya demostrar
este o es es el 1% ahí de la población
que pudiera obtener esta visa y eso es
lo que ha hecho que las personas tengan
que venir por tierra entonces a pesar de
ser una buena noticia si no se
flexibilizan esos parámetros creo que va
a ser complejo que las personas cumplan
con esos requisitos y vamos a terminar
otra vez afectando a todos todo este
flujo a personas venezolanas que están
en condiciones muy complicadas ya lo
comentamos un poco previamente las
ciudades que están acogiendo a estos
migrantes venezolanos allí hay gritos de
alarmas sobre la capacidad de algunos de
sus albergues es sostenible esta medida
de deportaciones hacia México brevemente
por favor
quien realmente ha absorbido y creo que
va a absorber también a estos migrantes
venezolanos es la las organizaciones que
albergues tanto religiosos como en la
sociedad civil el gobierno está rebasado
para poder apoyar en este sentido